um dia minha mãe recebeu uma mensagem do
itamaraty únic rio mas pra entender por
que isso aconteceu temos que voltar um
pouco mais no tempo
agora que voltei no tempo estou com nove
anos de idade morando em uma cidade do
interior que se chama valinhos e gosto
muitíssimo de brincar ao ar livre no
jardim de casa
agora estou debaixo de uma árvore
sob a sombra fresca brincando com as
minhas bonecas mas sei lá eu eu não
brinco como todo mundo sabe
enquanto brincando eu penso nas pessoas
do mundo bem resta sou eu
estamos discutindo na cúpula da paz de
como podemos salvar as crianças das
guerras
estamos realizando uma super hiper
viagem de resgate já conseguimos vários
aviões para resgatar as famílias com
suas crianças e vamos levá las para um
lugar assim onde só tenha paz uma paz
plena mas nesse dia antes de eu ir
brincar eu tinha visto a imagem de um
pai
carregando seu filho morto nos braços
saindo dos escombros na cia
porque infelizmente sua casa tinha sido
bombardeada
quando vi aquela imagem eu fiquei quanto
como vida mas eu também fiquei com uma
grande vontade de ajudar aquela criança
e esse sentimento de querer ajudar
ele está crescendo ele cresce de uma
forma tão constante que não consigo
ficar parada sem fazer nada
aquilo ficou tão grudado na minha mente
que venho uma idéia de fazer uma música
porque desde pequeno eu amo escrever e
cantar músicas e aonde eu falo que os
problemas do mundo podem ser resolvidas
e é fácil levantar bandeira
há algo com solução pra mim essa música
que iria mudar o mundo
ela se chama pazzini o acompanha em 2012
estava estudando na escola tinha 10 anos
e folheando as páginas de um livro eu vi
a foto do prédio da onu em new york e eu
fiquei assim apaixonada pela aquela
imagem
e detalhe que nela de uma frase sim
minha irmã quando crescer quer trabalhar
na onu para ajudar a acabar com a
desigualdade aquilo despertou a minha
curiosidade sabe fez pau assim na minha
mente e fiquei mega curiosa perceber que
a onda como é que funciona isso sabe
então eu cheguei em casa e comecei a
prestar mais atenção nos noticiários e
eu vi que sempre diziam que a onu estava
ajudando as crianças que fugiam da
guerra estavam unindo os líderes
mundiais para discutirem questões de
como poderiam resolver os problemas do
mundo estavam buscando soluções
aí aconteceu um momento que eu realmente
não perde tempo
eu corri para pegar o computador liguei
ele é ele estava meio com os problemas
né pra ligar ele desligava sozinho né
então eu liguei de novo e entrei no site
da onu
e aí eu li sobre todo o trabalho que
eles fazem pelos quatro cantos do mundo
eu fiquei encantada sabe só que detalhe
que nesse site da onu não tinha fale
conosco
então eu tive que é virar a internet de
cabeça pra baixo pra achar o contato
deles para conseguir enviar uma mensagem
que estava doida prevê
depois de muito tempo horas
eu quando encontrei o contato deles eu
fiquei mega feliz né porque todo esforço
vale a pena e corri pra escrever a
mensagem desesperadamente e nela eu me
ofereci para
a ajudá los a resolver todo tipo todos
mesmo todos os problemas do mundo é aos
10 anos de idade e é também enviei a
minha música para a união que era uma
ótima oportunidade para os adultos
poderão me ouvir
tá só que detalhe que pra gravar aquela
música é eu instalei um gravador no
computador dos meus pais e eu não sabia
direito o que era né os gravadores que
era oficial de algum site não e banho
enche o computador dele de vírus e é
computador de trabalho deles mas deu
tudo certo ea casa era boa né ai detalhe
que na mensagem eu coloquei contato dos
meus pais porque já estava imaginando
que a onu
alguém da onu poderia telefonar pra
querer saber sobre as minhas propostas e
tv só depois de alguns poucos dias assim
demorou muito não fui rápido pra minha
surpresa e para surpresa da minha mãe
ela receber uma mensagem por e-mail do
itamaraty únic rio querendo contratar
responsável da ingrid solto
agora a gente imagina a cara da minha
mãe quando viu e meio do itamaraty
querendo contratar responsável da ingrid
com certeza respondeu não foi normal não
foi anormal
não sei se eu teria a mesma reação mas
enfim a saiu correndo no meu quarto onde
estava brincando ela chegou assim com os
olhos arregalados assustada eu amo o que
eu faço qualquer coisa antes que eu
perguntar se ela estava bem assim
o que você fez
porque é para que as mães a é quando vão
perguntar alguma coisa pra vocês já
pensa que você fez algo de errado e aí
quando eu ia falar falou você aqui algum
site do governo que eu sei que minha mãe
foi sim faço aqui um site do governo se
é você aqui alguma coisa é bem
importante porque tem um pessoal que ele
falar que comigo e eu não sei o que é
você vai me falar a verdade depois de
demorar uns segundos em silêncio assim
filha enquanto a verdade eu sou a melhor
amiga você sabe que pode contar comigo
né não precisa mentir
aí foi nesse momento que eu pensei bem e
falei nossa as nossas mães quando querem
descobrir alguma coisa elas são nossas
melhores amigas
aí eu achei também muito engraçado o
fato de ela ter achado que eu tinha
criado um site do governo aos 10 anos
como assim eu não sei mas ela foi marca
criativa
aí eu expliquei pra ela que eu enviei
uma mensagem para a onu já coloquei o
contato dela porque ele estava
imaginando triz poderiam querer ouvir ea
reação dela novamente foi tipo ela não
acredito em nada no primeiro momento o
primeiro no dia inteiro acreditou no
segundo dia já ficou mega feliz entendeu
que era verdade eu não arranquei um site
e o meu pai também suprime apoiou a
gente já tinha várias planos vários
projetos idealizados para serem
implantadas ao redor do mundo e já dá
pra imaginar que desde então eu não
parei mais e eu não consegui ficar
parada por isso que eu estou aqui agora
em 2013 eu estava com 11 anos de idade
vocês se lembram que nesse ano tinha
começado um grande movimento de pessoas
refugiados no mundo que atravessando
fronteiras ou mesmo até os mares em
busca de proteção e direito à vida
muitas famílias com suas crianças
debaixo de frio sol chuva passando fome
dificuldades
tudo tudo isso pra fugir da guerra
quando fiquei sabendo daquilo que vocês
já podem imaginar que eu decidi me
mobilizar
mas eu queria fazer algo além da música
porque nessa altura eu já tinha mais de
30 músicas e já era possível encontrar
várias composições minhas ao redor da
casa minha mãe fica louca por conta
disso até hoje acontece o encontro
vários debaixo da minha cama também amar
usinadas para o momento certo para lançá
las mas faltava alguma coisa sabia
sentindo meu coração que precisava fazer
algo a mais
você se lembra daquela imagem do pai
carrega no seu filho na síria que ficou
na minha mente
ela me fez refletir muito porque já
estava pensando como eu poderia ajudar
as crianças que sofriam nas guerras b e
outra vez assistindo ao noticiário
depois eles mudam muitíssimo a minha
vida é decidir outra vez mobilizar eu
vou contar sobre um projeto pra vocês eu
ver que crianças e famílias refugiadas
estavam sendo acolhidas aqui no brasil
e pra mim foi uma ótima oportunidade pra
conseguir ajudá las porque é meu grande
sonho desde pequeno
então eu criei a campanha de coleta de
brinquedos e livros em prol das crianças
refugiados que chegam no brasil essa
imagem minha irmã e a homem acnur super
apoiaram abraçaram a idéia e me
colocaram em contato com algumas
famílias refugiadas
hoje eu vou para as escolas façam
palestras
explico a situação de refugiados das
crianças né presidente também canto onde
a música principal é é faziam que fez
isto disse mú começar e as crianças e
adolescentes também fazem carta de
boas-vindas entregam dou um brinquedo ou
um livro e esse é um sinal de que nossa
geração não está perdida e também já dá
para imaginar que a primeira escola que
acolheu recebeu muito bem por sinal a
campanha a de ver com a minha escola é o
ponto principal de coleta e sempre será
assim
eu também já queria que mais crianças e
adolescentes se mobilizassem porque ia
despertar a curiosidade delas e saber o
que realmente é estar refugiado que não
é que a pessoa está fugindo assim o que
é que a maioria porque a maioria das
pessoas pensa que a pessoa está fugindo
porque fez algo de errado a gente estar
refugiado é quando a pessoa tem seu
direito de liberdade de expressão e de
viver violados e quando outras escolas
também você tem que imaginar que as
crianças ficam eufóricas o ano inteiro
se preparam para a campanha é inclusive
no ano passado doaram até chave de carro
celular também as suas irmãs pegando
todas as coisas dos irmãos e doaram
também né
eu não me responsabilizo por isso mas
elas adoraram fazer isso e os pais devem
ter adorado nosso carro a chave do carro
foi doada vai ajudar uma criança assim
porque eu fiz essa campanha pra levar
essas crianças essas adolescentes essas
famílias que estão sendo colhidas aqui
no brasil que fogem das guerras que
lutam pelo direito à vida
que elas se sintam acolhidas
quando você dá um brinquedo um livro pra
uma criança você pode ver a sensação de
bem estar e alegria é muito nítida sabe
você vê uma criança fica muito alegre
sabe é a criança também fica muito mais
feliz quando sabe que outra criança do o
seu brinquedo pra ela um simples
brinquedo mesmo que seja usado ele pode
ajudar a trazer de volta a criatividade
ea reconstrução de seus sonhos que podem
ter sido até perdidos ao longo da
jornada dela pra vocês verem assim por
outro lado e não tão menos importante as
crianças que dom seus brinquedos elas
vêem o mundo de uma forma diferente
elas vêm o como é importante para as
outras crianças o direito de brincar
sabe como é importante você ajudar o
próximo e que não existe idade pra isso
pra vocês terem uma ideia como a nossa
geração também a mega solidária que isso
é trilegal no ano passado e conseguiu
arrecadar mais de 10 mil brinquedos de
todos os tipos
assim o resultado não foi lindo
foi magnífico foi maravilhoso porque
foram distribuídos os brinquedos todos
para duas ongs aqui em são paulo
atendendo dia das crianças e até o natal
a gente também não pode esquecer que
estamos no brasil então pensa que não é
fácil juntar as pessoas transportar as
doações fazer a entrega
fazer acontecer se eu que comecei tudo
tudo isso aos 10 anos de idade
imagine-se mais crianças e adolescentes
tivessem a mesma atitude até a campanha
por exemplo poderia alcançar muito mais
lugares poderia ajudar muito mais
pessoas também
e é o meu sonho é que esta campanha que
eu faço que já estou no quarto ano dela
essa campanha se estende para o planeta
inteiro e que chegue até os campos de
refugiados no norte da áfrica oriente
médio pois a gente nós temos 28 milhões
de crianças em situação de refúgio que
precisam da nossa ajuda
mas olha a cada dia sem perceber estamos
nos unindo um muitíssimo mais
persistindo com muita coragem que
paciência se expressando em busca do
futuro a gente também vê geralmente a
cada dia
todos os anos as crianças e adolescentes
desenvolvendo pequenas soluções para os
problemas mundiais mundo isso é incrível
tudo incrível e os nossos objetivos são
tão imensas que nós não podemos recuar e
muito menos abrir mão deles sabe muitas
vezes nós temos sonhos inovadores porque
independente da nossa cidade é possível
sim transformar o futuro no presente a
cada minuto segundo estamos cada vez
mais pertos do futuro
isso é muito louco o que você está
fazendo agora pode ser seu futuro
você já pensou nisso
sejam muito bem vindos ao futuro